my name is joseph taylor and i'm
professor of physics emeritus at
Princeton University I happen to have
been awarded the nobel prize in physics
in 1993 my own work is in astrophysics
has to do with the discovery of pulsars
and their interaction particularly in a
binary pulsar system that gave us
confidence that gravitational radiation
as predicted by Einstein's relativity
theory actually exists I've had a
wonderful life in in science and in
physics I believe that science is
extraordinarily important in today's
world important to the development of
technologies which have made life more
happy and in generally more prosperous I
think it's extremely important to the
nation and to other nations that
scientific knowledge inform public
policy and that's the primary reason
that I'm here at this session today I
simply want to lend my support to the
efforts that are being made to limit the
distribution of nuclear weapons to limit
their number two in fact stigmatize them
to the effect that they will be seen as
negative contributions to to the
stability of the world and the good for
for the citizens of the world
[Music]
[Music]
I